today we're going to be speaking with
edward miller who's a professor at
northeastern university also author of
the book a conspiratorial life robert
welch the john birch society and the
revolution of american conservatism
really appreciate your time today
oh it's my pleasure it's a great
opportunity to to discuss the book and
uh
to talk with you
yeah so to start with you know we've
been thinking a lot about this line in
conservatism that got
us to where we are today and we could
sort of start that story at a lot of
different points in time
um i think an interesting place to start
might might be if we go back to robert
welch and the john birch society to
start kind of creating our understanding
of how things got to be the way they are
uh
who who was robert welch and and talk
about his relevance to modern day
conservatism a little bit
well robert welch was a candy
manufacturer from
the south he was originally from north
carolina
and he was a very successful candy
manufacturer he created such childhood
favorites as the
sugar daddy and the junior mints
and he um
he decided it was his career was done
for
uh making money and then he decided to
get involved in
uh anti-communist activity and establish
an organization called the john birch
society uh this organization tended to
be of a conspiracy
conspiratorial bent
uh with the major highlight being that
uh welch believed that president
eisenhower was a communist which of
course is
is ridiculous uh but
uh he continued to establish this john
birch society and it and it and it
became the
the most powerful anti-communist
organization in the
in the early 1960s late 1950s
and as i argue in the book
had influence even into the 70s during
the
the um the age of reagan
of which we're probably still in and
when we think about the
mccarthy era and and sort of that
reactionary fear-mongering basis on
which you know we we need to be
suspicious of people with certain
ideologies and we need hearings etc
that paradigm in different forms has has
really persisted throughout the 20th
century and into the 21st among the
american right wing has it not
oh absolutely the
um
the the claims of
um treason
that are that were echoed by mccarthy
uh that were echoed by uh william jenner
he was another another senator
uh that were echoed by william noland
these these kind of um
aspersions continue on into the
republican party in in the present
it didn't have to go this way in the
sense that i mean i think an interesting
anecdote is william f buckley who we
don't have to be fans of his or praise
him or anything to to recognize that
buckley's instincts were very much
antithetical to the idea of welch i
think in my understanding and this kind
of red scare type stuff where buckley
seemed to think that the right was going
to do better by taking a sort of less
reactionary
approach is that accurate and why i mean
did did that succeed for a period of
time until it again reversed or what's
the history of that
i think it succeeded for a brief period
of time but uh buckley was an excellent
order
and historian he was a gatekeeper of the
far right and
he was also i mean this was his pet
project to create the conservative
movement of the
uh of the 20th century
and
he saw a threat to the conspiratorial
behavior
in the john birch society and he
concluded that it was best that john
burt that
robert welch leave the organization or
be settled as he said into the
editorial room where he could do less
damage
and um
for for a long time we thought that
historians we thought that
uh
buckley had excommunicated welch but i
began to take a look at
uh what was going on and what the john
birch society had done
after the period that they were
uh traditionally known as being in exile
the period 66 to 68 but i found that i
found in my research that welch changed
the organization
focused on ad hoc
issues
through ad hoc committees
and push pushed issues that became
consonant with the reagan revolution
issues such as abortion
issues such as
the equal rights amendment anti-taxation
issues these all became uh part of the
um
part of the fabric of the of the reagan
revolution
and it pushed that the reagan revolution
in that particular direction
uh in the 1970s so i
i found that welch welch was more
significant than we thought
it seems to me that
had the sort of buckley wing won out
you would not have seen maybe the tea
party
the trump wave
q anon even a lot of the kind of modern
outcroppings of this the anti-vaxx it it
i mean i guess we can't say for sure but
it seems that those movements follow
much more from the conspiratorial welch
side than from maybe what buckley wanted
well it's of course we can't we
historically it's a tough um yes the
tough um
we can't determine with exactitude that
that would happen uh conspiratorial
thinking has become more popular in our
uh in our culture
ever since watergate and the 1970s when
um when the church committee came out as
as
when the iran contra affair
occurred in the 1980s when
um the you had figures like alex jones
and rush limbaugh in the 1990s
pushing their
um
their views
but i i think it's true that if it was
if it was just buckley and welch was not
part of the
uh part of the
the scene it probably would have been a
lot different
i'm curious to what degree the realities
of media and the development of the
internet uh had as as a role in all this
there's this book waves of rancor which
is sort of a look at uh
you know the history of how did talk
radio and am radio become right wing and
the connection between uh churches and
like low power religious radio you know
a lot of this nitty gritty stuff but it
seems to me
that
the more conspiratorial
welch
type thinking
lent itself much better to
the radio space and media space than
maybe what buckley
was more known for and i wonder to what
degree the realities of media influence
the direction of the american right
oh i think without a doubt the the in
the influence of the
of talk radio especially after
um
the fa the end of the fairness doctrine
um
you definitely see an increase in
conspiratorial thinking if you if you
take a look at
um
how
rush limbaugh phrases
conspiratorial thinking on his show he
would just
allude to something in the facts
you know and say well this is what i
read in the facts to avoid libel or
something like that uh but
he did imply this conspiratorial
thinking very very
casually along with michael savage and
and
other
um
other conservative radio hosts
uh who had who had
adopted that tradition glenn beck
so these figures are important as well i
i'm not
diminishing their role but before all
this comes
robert welch who is setting up
this uh
this way of thinking this different way
of thinking and he is
uh joined by
other radio
uh folks like dan smoot
who is a
uh a dallas-based former fbi g-man
who worked for
h.l hunt who comes to his own conclusion
and
concludes that
it was not a communist conspiracy per se
that was driving things but an anti but
a globalist conspiracy yes that
which is part of the
um
part of the language that you see in in
stephen bannon's politics today speaking
of not of a not of a conspiracy of
communism but of globalists and
internationalists and and welch was
speaking that language
by the end of his life as well yeah i
mean i i'm do is it fair to say that
right now the american right is as
conspiratorial as it's ever been as
indicated by i mean you know recent
polls of republicans more than half
believe trump is actually the winner of
the 2020 election
the degree to which they question
whether vaccines work whether covet is
real or you know what however we define
is
is there any time at which the bulk of
the republican party believed things
like this
i can't i can't in my in my knowledge of
all of all the time in the 1980s and the
1970s and 60s i think the early 60s
there was a significant um
belief in that particular direction
the um
but i i think that the pen the
combination of the pandemic
um and
uh
the
um the the
trump's refusal to admit the reality
that he lost the presidential election
uh
and
his willingness to tout this to his his
base continue to tout it to his base
has had a a significant impact so
what can reverse the course of a
movement that is so committed to that
type of thinking um i mean i think you
know to some degree if they start losing
they would probably be forced into
rethinking it i i guess
uh but i mean what sort of forces can
really turn around a movement like that
well i i always but
you know i i always
this is a great question and i always
consider this myself when you know i'm
encountered with somebody who has a
different perspective of
from how i look at um how i would look
at something
that i would see as
not nefarious you know i would just see
it as the mistakes of individuals or
let's take the loss of
the loss of china
in the 1950s in the 19 after 1949 many
republicans were blaming
the democrats for the loss of china and
they were focusing on the treason of
elected officials uh dean atchison and
george marshall
even um even harry truman
and they were pinpointing
welch included were pinpointing that um
truman was a traitor
or at least atchison and marshall were
traitors in this
process
i'm more apt to see
individual mistakes
and uh the fact that
uh the chinese people had decided on uh
chiang kai-shek
uh in that particular case so i i look
at it
uh as an opportunity each time to talk
to people on a personal level and try to
speak to them about this the history of
it
and
you know if that doesn't work uh
right right i mean i think the question
that a lot of people are kind of
grappling with and looking at the
direction of the republican party over
the last six years in particular and
then even even just a little bit longer
is sort of like what's the kind of end
game here and part of it may be that
this is just an indefinite means like
there there's there's not necessarily an
end in the sense of you know earlier in
the week we looked on the show at a clip
of glenn beck recently interviewing
james lindsay where they're talking in
extreme like it's almost like a modern
red scare type language about they're
gonna put us if we're not in cages we
have to be ready to resist and it's just
like it could be applied to anything
it's like are you talking about vaccines
or democrats or
uh
china or like what it almost is just
this universal language that's not super
clear but you're supposed to be very
scared about it um and it seems almost
like it's just a means to its own
self-preservation rather than to some
end
yeah i would agree i think
i listened to a lot of the the you know
the far-right shows because it's part of
my job and yeah
if you hear some of the things coming
out of mike lindell of the the pillow
guy yep
for instance he's
he's still trying to overturn the
ballots and um yeah i've interviewed him
and i'll tell you he seems to be a true
believer i mean in my conversation with
him off air he seems to really believe
this stuff
oh okay so you've talked with him oh
yeah
oh yeah wow
um that's fascinating it was it was
i i would yes i would put him down as a
true believer and i would put robert
welch down as a true believer i i have
nose um after reading
this book i have no sense that this was
done
for
um
histrionics he wasn't doing this to earn
money he gave he gave every cent
of his um of his millions
to
um to fight windmills in a sense he was
the don quixote of um
of of the conservative movement uh
and
but there are still
folks who are committed to
uh this
canard
that we see as a canard and and
uh
but
how to deal with that i think we're all
wrestling with that yeah
it remains an open question uh for for
sure um the book is a conspiratorial
life robert welch the john birch society
and the revolution of american
conservatism we've been speaking with
the book's author northeastern
university professor edward miller
really appreciate your insights today
oh it was a great pleasure i i very much
enjoyed it